[Music]
dan is with us in ventura california hi
dan how are you
hi dave hi george i'm i'm doing uh
pretty good i was in your studio
audience last thursday and it was just
wonderful
thank you seeing you all in person it
was so reassuring and just it just made
me uh just lock down on the baby steps
cool when i got home i was back home in
ventura i i'm i'm a little confused
right now because i thought i was in
baby step six
um and my question is uh what revolves
around spousal support so
um
i'm wondering where spousal support fits
in the baby steps
i just finished my
divorce
about three months ago and my world has
been quite rocked
the last year or so i'm sorry
yeah so alimony would that not just be a
budget item george yeah is this just
ongoing support what's the details of
this
yeah yeah the the basic the details are
i'm obligated to pay 2 000 a month until
february next year i mean i've already
already paid off the attorneys and
lumps on payments and you know the all
the bad part of the divorce is is
over um except for the spousal support
so i'm paying you know i'm i'm 58 years
old uh on my home i make about 102
dollars a year
um and i've been just cash flowing it
and but i do have the emergency fund of
about fifteen thousand i could use just
just to pay it off a hundred percent
so is this a one you could lump sum this
spousal support if you wanted to
well now there that's a good question
and the marital separation agreement
says i'm supposed to pay her a few
thousand dollars a month until for 11
months
yeah which ends in february
and you can just do that out of your
budget can't you
i i have been and i can yeah i would
just call as far as it's not really a
baby step item it's a budget item
i'll budget that okay yeah you have a 2
000 expense in your budget that's going
to go away in february
right it doesn't affect your baby steps
that's what i think i don't know what do
you think about a different way consider
it as debt i wouldn't say oh you're in
baby step 2 now you got to pay this
thing off it's just a budget line item
and once it's done you're going to give
yourself a raise and you can continue on
in the baby steps after that but you
said you have no debt except the house
right
that's correct you know no debt except
for the house and i hope to be on your
debt-free stage in about four years
that's great do you have margin left
over after the spousal support to put
extra on the mortgage
no
i have a part-time gig i'm also an
electrician on the side so i'm able to
make you know
maybe a thousand dollars extra a month
um but it's tight right now very tight
in fact i'm i'm
i'm trying to make some behavioral
changes uh so are you you owe her twelve
thousand dollars uh six months of two
thousand bucks right
yes sir how contentious is the
relationship
uh
i think that answers it
it's not good
okay because here's why i ask okay you
could just do the two thousand dollars a
month for for six months that's fine and
you're done if it was if you called me
up and you said i have five years of
back alimony
i would call that a debt
and that's a lump sum that you got to
catch up but this is a monthly
obligation that you are current on
and it's not a debt it's just a payout
now if uh
depending on how contentious here's an
idea to throw into the soup might not be
worth anything but you might have your
attorney asked her attorney if he pays
this off in a lump sum would there be a
discount more than willing to pay it
monthly but if you want all the money
right now would you take less than 12
000 and i'd use my emergency fund and
clear it up if you got a deal
okay plus it gets rid of heart i did
yeah yeah exactly that's what i was
thinking to kind of get it out of my
life we're no longer using attorneys
we're communicating through email i
asked that question about two months ago
she says absolutely not you have to you
know abide by the agreement sure then
i'll do it that was my answer right here
sure yeah happy too just leave it alone
then forget it okay
okay my idea you've already tried my
idea forget it yeah because i didn't
think you know because sometimes people
need money or they want the lump sum
enough to give it a discount if they're
not going to give it a discount we'll
just sit on the money and pay it out
monthly
which it sounds like she prefers anyway
so it's all right it's all good that's
fine
i think so i think yeah so that's the
route i would go yeah and once you're
once you hit february then you've got
two thousand dollars back in your life
to pay down that mortgage and it sounds
like you're you want to be intense about
it and get rid of that thing so i think
you're in a good situation like dave's
saying i think you just make these
monthly payments out of your budget
and be done with it in six months